seitdem ich hier auf dem kanal an den
unendlichen stromgenerator zum selbst
kurbeln gebaut habe frage ich mich wie
viel strom man damit machen könnte wenn
man statt der eigenen drehbewegung
einfachen hamsterrad anzapfen würde nun
denn ich habe leider kein hamster aber
ich habe nein thomas also ist der
einzige logische nächste schritt das
weltweit wahrscheinlich erste xxx xxl
hamsterrad für menschen zu bauen dass
beim laufen einfach öko strom generiert
kann ich damit einen ganzen fernseher
betreiben oder sogar noch viel mehr
finden wir draußen dieses video wird
unterstützt durch die one von ashley
greenes mehr dazu am ende des videos
aber bevor ich die ganze stadt mit
ökostrom versorgen kann muss ich mir
erst mal überlegen wie um alles in der
welt ich eine über zwei meter großes und
komplett größenwahnsinniges hamsterrad
überhaupt bauen will ursprünglich wollte
ich das riesen hamsterrad übrigens in
meiner wohnung bauen in köln da das aber
absolut aberwitzig wäre hatte mein kater
felix idee eine werkstatt zu mieten da
die aber nicht mal für 900 euro miete
bock auf mich um eine dumme idee hatten
wenn ich jetzt hier am haus meiner
eltern in bayern dank auf ihre mama papa
dass wir sind hier mitmacht und das
nächste problem ist hamster räder sind
bekannt dafür schon unzählige handwerker
kehrt zu haben wenn man beim verlassen
des rates zwischen sie sprechen ja kommt
und das ganze gestellt um die 100 kilo
weg dann kann das echt übel ausgehen und
das brauchen wir nicht also brauche ich
ein modernes konstrukt das viel
komplizierter ist also ich kann
theoretisch aus stahl machen aber ich
hasse es mit stahl zu arbeiten man
könnte das holz zu dem rat bieten die
bei einem fass aber das würde wochen
dauern der riesige holz zu nehmen und
dann einfach runter aussehen keine
ahnung wie das transportieren sollte
aber ich habe da noch eine andere idee
ich konstruiere also das gesamte
konstrukt einmal am computer bevor ich
auch nur anfangen zu bauen zwei ringe
bestehend aus jeweils sechs segmenten
und dutzende um genau zu sein 66 bretter
die alle zusammen halten danach das
gestell auf dem sich das rad drehen wird
ich mache also eine lange einkaufsliste
und damit auch zum baumarkt ich muss
mehrere meter holz brauchen die größten
platten die ich brauche sind zwei meter
fünfzig ja ich habe dafür genau dieses
auto von maria und angespannt dass die
leute denken werden wenn ich damit auf
tollste aber
machst du nix
[Musik]
soweit das auge reicht holzplatten
das könnte sich jetzt einfach riesig
[Musik]
die sonst an sich oder
so
kann man schon mal machen der
mitarbeiter der das hier gerade
zugeschnitten hat hat mich gefragt was
ich damit ein schönes bau und ich musste
sagen ich brauche haben zu erwarten
das problem ist ja noch nicht viel damit
machen ich muss mich morgen erstmal eine
schweinerei elektronikteile für den
generator mit dem ich dann später strom
erzeugen weil die kommen auch erst
morgen oder übermorgen wobei ich mir die
ganze sache nachdem ist jetzt ganz
ausgeräumt hab noch an zeichnen und das
kann
[Musik]
man kann nicht alle zwei stunden
verbracht
[Musik]
so akzentfrei
und ich hoffe einfach mal dass der
schweizer den mein dad kennt heute zeit
zwischen den jahren am 27 september auch
viele betriebe haben da
verständlicherweise sehr komplexe
die schweinerei hatte lag eine bandsäge
weil sie auch nicht ganz versteht das
kommt mir vor wie so ein friseur
irgendwie keine schere hat na ja auf
jeden fall hat der besitzer von der
schreinerei zu seinem typ der direkt
daneben stand gesagt hey du hast ein
seekabel zu hause und jetzt macht es mir
weniger fremde mann der hat natürlich
auch erst mal gefragt was ich damit
treibt und der war auf einmal von der
idee begeistert dass ich mich deshalb
ist auch in wallgau also können wir das
dorfleben richtig hart am start und das
jetzt um 5000 seelen dorf ist glaube ich
auch so ein bisschen erst sobald die
ganze stadt spricht
[Musik]
man wolle
so gab es an meiner garage alle
einzelnen holz segmente zusammen
gesetzte zu diesen riesigen lauf ringen
vom hamsterrad die sind relativ dick und
müssen dann auch die gesamte last tragen
dass wir jetzt erstmal mit stall flach
verbinden verbinden und hoffentlich
bricht das dann nicht auseinander
sondern bildet zwei richtig sowie die
kreise so dass die über 300 schrauben
die wir dafür brauchen werden
[Musik]
lasst uns
so der erste ist fertig der ist
allerdings deutlich außen noch nicht
komplett perfekten und deswegen will ich
noch ein bisschen nachhelfen mit einer
flex und im schlaf aufsatz
[Musik]
das erste rad ist fertig wenn diese
ultra geil geil es ist einfach nur geil
wie sie rollt taktrate und wieder zurück
in die garage und versuchen nichts
kaputt zu machen
[Musik]
so die beiden großen dinge sind fertig
und auch hier schön verstärkt also das
ist bombenfest jetzt kommt weil sie
diese bretter dazwischen die werden dann
hier quasi so einmal im kreis reingelegt
gleich wer das jetzt dafür gleich
vorbeugung zwar den abstand von hier
oben hat ausgesehen von 53 zentimeter
habe ich mir aus gemessen da muss ich
jetzt quasi 64 blätter vor bohren und
dann hereinlegen das wird glaube ich
jetzt ja und damit wir das nicht 128 mal
ablassen müssen habe ich eine coole
konstruktion gebaut und mit der
konstruktion kann man dann einfach die
holzbretter reinlegen dann genau in
dieses eine loch hier durchbohren einmal
das bett umdrehen und dann auch daran
wollen und schon hat man die perfekten
bohrungen ohne jedes mal messen zu
müssen wir sind schon dabei die bretter
hier anzuschrauben das ding es ist
einfach aber witzig es ist einfach so
komplett war es ist wahnsinnig geil
[Musik]
anschließend wird das vor gebäude brett
an die beiden holzring gelegt und eins
nach dem anderen entsprechend
festgeschraubt
[Musik]
es ist ganz vielleicht mit diesen
brettern die hier rein gibt's immer
wurden ganz perfekt jetzt aber wir sind
schon kurz davor das ding fertig zu
machen
hob hinlegen geht natürlich nicht
perfekt auf da muss man natürlich dann
ja noch mal ein halbes brett segen wo
das muss ich auch machen könnte ist dass
wir alle jetzt quasi in dem ein
zentimeter abstand hier so rein macht
habe ich glaube ein brett durchsägen wer
glaub ich schlauer
[Musik]
und jetzt dieses perfekte stück hier und
das passt auch auf anhieb ziemlich geil
rein und er ist werde ich schraube ist
kurz ran
so einmal und natürlich hier auch zwei
mal
fertig geil es ist unfassbar geil ist
einfach huge es ist riesig es ist viel
zu wahnsinnig dass dinge
es ist wirklich unnormal groß also
wirklich unnormal es passt gerade diese
gage rhein ist es [ __ ] stabil als er
arbeitet schon ein bisschen aber
es ist halt eigentlich schon unter
sterben er war zweiter bremsklötze
drohte damit das teil jetzt nicht
einfach komplett die einfach runter
segelt der nächste schritt ist es für
dieses laufrad mit diesen beiden
hölzernen hier einmal ein schönes
standfuß zu bauen damit es dem sie
auftreten können
[Musik]
das ist mein leben ich bin ja weil die
konstruktion digital hat man muss immer
mal wieder schauen wo genau wochen
hinkommen und seinen sport besorgt
perfekt war da geht's
[Musik]
ganz komplett beschissene situation
damit ich mit dem generator später genug
energie krieg brauche ich da am ende der
drehung von über 4000 umdrehungen pro
minute und da ich mit diesem wetter
natürlich nicht so schnell laufen können
werde funktioniert es mit einem zahn
getriebe dass es halt hoch geschaltet
werde darunter gestalten wird wie ihn im
auto eben ja und dafür hab ich ganz
wichtige teile jetzt eigentlich
hergestellt dachte ich zumindest gesehen
haben jetzt in köln weil sie eine
falsche adresse bestellt haben jetzt
gibt's ein paar option internet von köln
herschicken selbst mit express dauert
das allerdings jetzt zwei tage aber am
donnerstag in bayern feiertag ist und da
sind nicht schnell genug weil ich nur
bis ende der woche noch bei meinen
eltern bin und ich kann das riesenrad ja
nicht nach köln mit dem das werk
komplett verrückt die nächste option
wäre das zeug einfach neu zu bestellen
aber selbst das wird zu lange dauern ja
und das ist dann die einzige option mehr
angefasst die schnell genug wäre oder
stunde hat thomas sehr gute mir gesagt
dass pakete in köln angekommen sind und
eigentlich in bayern sein ich bin und
ich bin heute der neue postbote
[Musik]
so ist das halt wenn man für thomas
so herrn johann deren man jetzt schon
unterwegs sein solltest dich jetzt
erstmal ob diese elektromotor bei dem
man ja eigentlich hinten rein strom raus
gibt und dann in bremen zu bekommen ob
der einfach hinten raus strom spuckt
wenn ich die drehung selber ist wie bei
den generator oder ob ich das fordert
irgendwie irgendwas umstellen muss ich
habe dafür zwei spiel klären mit einem
plus von minus pol hat schon ganz viele
kleine leds derzeit mal ich musste ja zu
drehen ich glaube nicht dass meine hand
stoffe ausreicht das merken wir dann
abgedrückt
andere richtung wo es funktioniert
einfach ich hätte niemals gedacht dass
es so schnell geht neu ich muss ja gar
nix ist schon mega geil
das ist also das hätte ich nicht gedacht
dass wir einmal geht ja okay dann warte
ich jetzt einfach sein weil sonst habe
ich nichts anderes zu tun wobei probiert
mal so richtig wild ist und zwar an
statt jetzt hier nicht glühbirne zu
betreiben geht ja mal direkt an den
anderen elektromotor an und versuche das
jetzt so zu betreiben kann ob das klappt
no way das klappt
er dreht sich er dreht sie nicht schnell
aber er dreht sich ist ja geil das ist
so lustig kann ich das jetzt einfach
anders rum drauf stecken dass ich den
hier einfinden
das geht noch mal viel mehr also geht
halt richtig gas durchhänger mal tape
dran und jetzt soll das halt abgeben
naja das kind heftig ist
[Musik]
ich habe einfach mitgemacht
hätte ich nicht gedacht dass man
elektromotor einfach so als generator
und irgendwann dachte man muss doch
irgendwas bisschen modifizieren so nun
ist da und wir sagen ich zeigen sie mal
wenn sie mal anstellen muss aufpassen
kann es jetzt nicht drehen das hatte
brands kürzer muss ich aufpassen aber
mit kannst du dich
[Musik]
so
so manchmal was drin ist
zahnräder aluplatten hier stück step
down converter land kugellager mehr
pflanzen lager im café reise in kamenz
messer gekauft
dankeschön
[Musik]
jetzt sei es da die baustelle kann
weitergehen
zu dem nächsten schritt muss ich jetzt
quasi auf diese achse zweimal diese
rolle drauf machen damit dann quasi
später das rad darauf laufen kann und
die außen am jetzt nicht ausbrechen kann
einfach so eine begrenzte scheibe und
dafür muss ich das in die videonale
anzeigen dann noch in die mitte bohren
und dann das ding auch ungefähr ein
bisschen und flexen so dass gleich mit
ungefähr so vor dass die amazon regen
dran kommt er an diese alte scheibe dann
diese rolle hier dann noch so ein
begrenzt stück wie andere seite dann
nochmal genau das gleiche nur umgedreht
kommt das ja auf die rechte seite durch
andere kugellager dann schreibe ich die
welle jetzt hier im kugl außen fest
und an und für sich wird der abstand
jetzt auch genau schon passen und darauf
kann dann quasi dieses hätte laufrad das
problem ist nur an diesen rollen sind
auch schon bereit sein das heißt wenn
man jetzt hier drauf sind wird kaum
kraft auf diese dicke achse hier
aufgebracht und deswegen muss ich diese
rollen noch an dieser achse hier fest
schweißen
[Musik]
guten morgen auf der baustelle
ich denke werde ich jeden morgen jedes
mal wenn ich anfangen was zum teufel
naja eigentlich ja heute ist die
hochzeit heute kommt das teil quasi auf
das gestell drauf haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schade irgendwie ist da schiefgelaufen
also die konzentration hat gestimmt hat
ja auch gepasst aber die umsetzung habe
ich dafür in falsch eingezeichnet ich
weiß nicht auf jeden fall muss ich jetzt
noch mal kurz das komplett neu
durchsägen uns einig mit einer schönen
bandsäge sondern diesmal in mühevoller
arbeit mit einer stichsäge
[Musik]
ok doch der moment der wahrheit kann man
da wieder laufen oder gehen zumindest
ihr okay das ist klar das muss ich auf
einmal daran gewöhnen
[Musik]
es bremst ein bisschen gut
das bremst noch ein bisschen zu stark
böig meist ähnliche rolle auf der seite
noch das in der spur bleibt ja so machen
was sie sagen wollen bestehen aus ganz
einfachen rollen aus dem baumarkt die
ich dann zusammen mit einem flach
verbinde an die holzkonstruktion
schraube und zwar genau so dass das rad
in der spur gehalten wird das große
haben sie rad dreht sich nun flüssig und
zwar ungefähr zwölf mal pro minute damit
der generator am ende aber genug strom
ausspuckt müssen am generator mindestens
4000 umdrehungen pro minute statt finden
dafür bauen wir mit achsen kugellagern
zahnriemen und zahnriemen scheiben eine
enorme umsetzung die drehbewegung
ungefähr 250 mal schneller jetzt gilt es
nun hoffen dass sie kein gummi räder
diese belastung auch aushalten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay der wahrheit wenn wir hier eine
extreme übersetzung also wenn ich mich
jetzt nur so ein bisschen bewegt dann
geht das ding von komplett ab wenn ich
mich nur ganz ganz weit nach vorne
lehnen dreht schon absolut durch ich
gehe mal gas
ok also 5000 umdrehungen sind sie drin
wenn ich schneller wer bestimmt auch
noch irgendwie 8000 die hat natürlich
spannend wieviel strom dabei rauskommen
wenn ich mittel schnell laufen kommen
tatsächlich leicht über 12 volt raus und
das ist für den monitor den ich damit
betreiben will viel zu viel dafür habe
ich dieses kleine teil bei dem ich links
zum beispiel 25 wollte reinschicken kann
und über die drehung an diese schraube
kann ich dann einstellen wie viel am
ende rauskomme zum beispiel hier exakt
die 12 volt die wir für den bildschirm
brauchen die spannung ist also begrenzt
damit aber nicht zuviel stromstärke bei
monitor ankommt baue ich noch eine
beziehungsweise zwei schaltungen rein
weil ich nicht weiß wo genau im
schaltkreis die hin kommen sollte ich
weiß auch nicht ob ich überhaupt eine
sicherung brauche aber hey schaden kann
es nicht und es funktioniert wenn ich
jetzt laufen kommen am ende maximal
zwölf freut raus ohne begrenzung schaffe
ich übrigens leicht über 25 volt und
mindestens sechs ampera also theoretisch
sollten weise locker 150 watt
produzieren können also glaube ich
zumindest der monitor der nur 25 watt
braucht sollte auf jeden fall drin sein
der moment der wahrheit ich habe jetzt
hier das irgendwie grob verkabelt
richtig schlecht gemacht später noch
schöner und das sollte jetzt theoretisch
funktionieren also mit meinem wissen
müsste jetzt nicht was im weg steht mein
wissen ist allerdings sehr begrenzt also
finden was einem praxistest raus
geschenkt das jetzt mal dem monitor ein
wir haben einmal auf 12 begrenzt ich
kann damit locker 20 25 volt generieren
aber eher begrenzt damit der motor
kaputt geht haben die sicherung auf drei
ampere sind dass da auch eigentlich
passieren sollte sich gehört
oh
mein gott es geht einmal es unfassbar
ist es unfassbar kreis also jetzt fehlt
natürlich noch was weil die ganze zeit
des staates wird schon zu sehen ist
natürlich sehr langweilig deswegen habe
ich mir das überlegt strom ist ja
offensichtlich genug da dann würde jetzt
ein bisschen aus dem mobilkom papst
reinzustecken dass ich da mein handy
drauf schreiben kann ich war mir sicher
meine eltern haben so ein gerät haben
sie nicht ich habe jetzt auf ebay
kleinanzeigen gefragt und jemand
gefunden und kann es direkt abholen mega
gut ich hoffe das klappt und ich hoffe
hätte ich person ist am ende nicht
irgendwie einfach gar nicht da
ja ich glaube ich dass ich durch das
teil hier ist ein kunde der fake das
einfach nicht ihr ding das ding kommt
sie überhaupt gar nicht hat nicht zum
bronze ging an google kommen kannst du
sagen außer dass es irgendwie so
außer dass irgendwie aus liebe ich habe
von den nächsten jahren in echten
cromcast hat es diesmal aber dafür muss
ich jetzt mal greifen stunde fahren aber
als ich mir bleibt nichts anders über ne
harke
da ist das ding sieht diesmal auch
original aus und jetzt nichts mit nach
hause so ein müll
[Musik]
selbst strom kommt es also aus dem
umgedrehten elektro mutter heraus in den
12 volt begrenzt von da aus geht er
direkt in den monitor der 12 volt
braucht allerdings ist hinten dran noch
mal 1 5 volt begrenzer an denen ich dann
bewusst nicht direkt den kreis
angesteckt haben sondern erstmal eine
usb buchse an dem man theoretisch sogar
noch handys anstecken könnte von ausgeht
der strom zum cromcast und theoretisch
sollte das ganze dinge zu funktionieren
wenn ich jetzt lauf sollte beides
gleichzeitig angehen und ich sollte mein
handy videos anschalten können
klimaneutral komplett autark feuer frei
[Musik]
gut
das hat jetzt gebrutzelt wo es auch
schlimm nicht verkaufen hätte hätte ich
in die andere richtung laufen müssen ich
will aber die richtung laufen als
service
passen
internet problem okay der wlan einfach
weil es mir so schlecht ich muss mal
kurz nachdem bruce schauen
[Musik]
die
es geht einfach geil ist nicht so
aufwendig einfach nochmal jetzt habe ich
aber noch das problem dass ich beim
laufen ja nicht auf dem monitor schauen
kann aber das will ich jetzt ändern
[Musik]
läuft das ganze teil jetzt mit tollem
ständer und dem monitor da dran und wie
ist die experience so kann man das
ändern kann man sich das geben ich teste
das für euch
es ist nicht ratsam staaten dazu auf
jetzt platt visa oder werden divx avi
video ein trampel
drauf
hast du ein bisschen warten bis das ist
ja das ist endlich
ansteckendes nicht betroffen hier
unsere aus
und schon kann man seinen lieben zu two
worlds ii sie anschauen wer ein profil
verbrennt
die windeln wichtigkeit man kann jetzt
garnicht winkel einstellen ja
aber wenn man dann kaputt ist dann geht
das ganze auch auf einmal genau ich das
teil noch ein bisschen upgraden soll
bleibt in dem aco dafür eine
viertelstunde strampeln kann und eine
ganze stunde schauen oder so aber das
war ein voller erfolg das spannende an
einem elektromotor den ich hier als
generator umfunktioniert haben ist ja
dass man wenn man auf der einen seite
drehungen rhein gibt hinten strom
rauskriegt aber natürlich auch wenn
hinten strom rhein gibt der drehung
heraus bekommt was würde jetzt also
passieren wenn ich den spieß umdrehen
und hinten einfach richtig viel strom
rein geht würde ich das hamsterrad dem
raps nun schnell drehen oder
funktioniert das überhaupt und könnte
ich dann hier drin noch mithalten damit
zu laufen auf meinem zweikanalton habe
ich genau das getestet das video findet
ihr jetzt gleich in der end card dieses
video wird unterstützt von eltern von
atlantic greens was für mich ein
wichtiger bestandteil von einer guten
morgen routine geworden ist jeden morgen
direkt nach dem aufstehen hauptmann sich
den guten löffel l gewann in seinen
shaker und ist direkt integriert und
kann in den tag starten
ein einziger löffel yuan ist vollgepackt
mit 75 essentiellen vitaminen
mineralstoffen und weiteren zutaten aus
vollwertigen und natürlichen
lebensmitteln die vor allem wenn du
unterwegs bist dann in der stoff lücke
schließen einmal am tag jeden tag welche
man kann fast alle anderen elemente
ersetzen und unterstützt seine
gesundheit zum beispiel immunsystem
energiehaushalt darmgesundheit mentalen
focus h & nagel gesundheit und viel mehr
wenn ihr euch ein gesünderes jahr 2022
vorgenommen habt dann solltet ihr
unbedingt mal ausprobieren geht auf
atletic kriens dot com / storari den
link findet ihr ein video beschreibung
und auch als angeboten kommentar und
erhaltet bei eurer ersten bestellung
dieses schicke edelstahl dose mit mass
löffel eine packung mit 30 portionen
diesen praktischen shaker und exklusiv
über meinen link zusätzlich nur fünf
dieser travel packs für unterwegs und
einen jahresvorrat an vitamin d3 was
besonders im winter wichtig ist dass wir
das sonst ja nur über die sonne bekommen
das war es damit von diesem video wie es
mit diesem rad weiter geht seht ihr
jetzt ein video auf mein zweikanal check
das gerne hierhin entkam ausland und
haben gleich wieder macht's gut
[Musik]